>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Maria Strong: So
welcome, everybody.
This is section six which is on
new ways to disseminate content
and the impact of moral rights.
My name is Maria Strong, I'm
with the copyright office.
And we're joined here today
with, to my immediate left,
Scott Martin, who is Executive
VP of IP for Paramount Pictures;
followed by Alec French of
Thorsen-French Advocacy,
representing today the
Directors Guild of America.
Next to him is Mr.
Stan Pierre-Louis
who is Senior Vice
President and General Counsel
of the Entertainment
Software Association.
Next is Roxana Robinson,
author and President
of the Author's Guild.
And at the end is
Mr. Chris Castle
of Christian L. Castle
Attorneys.
Today, as we've heard, we have
the opportunity to sort of wrap
up all of the exciting
things that we've heard
in the panels before us,
but also to really hear more
about the importance of
contracted transactions
and distribution practices.
On this panel, we
have representatives
from private corporations,
from guilds,
from organizations
representing individual authors.
So this is an opportunity for
us to explore with you some
of the issues that
have been raised today,
as well as at the end, we'll
maintain some questions --
time for you all to ask us.
So with that, what
I'd like to do is open
up with a question
for all of them.
We'll go down the line,
and then we'll start
up with more individual
questions just
to get the conversation going.
So for everyone -- the question
that they have to consider
and answer for you all is:
what are the most
important elements present
in your industry that contribute
to supporting the concepts
of attributing author's
interest in the final work
and for protecting the integrity
of the author's contributions?
And what are the
biggest challenges
that you face in your sector?
And with that, we're going to
start with Mr. Scott Martin.
>> Scott Martin: And I should
probably note, Steve Marks,
who is supposed to be with
us, is under the weather,
which is why he's not here.
I really wanted to have
his placard in front of me,
because then I'd have
complete deniability.
"Did you hear what
Steve Marks said today
at the Copyright Office?"
[ Laughter ]
But they wouldn't give it to me.
In order to answer the
question, I brought some visuals
because I come from
a visual world
and I can't speak
without images.
And what I wanted to focus
on in answering Maria's
question is something
that we haven't really
touched on a lot today,
which is collective works.
We've been talking a lot
about individual work,
so works of things like
books, magazine articles,
photographs, sculptures.
I come from the world
of collective works,
which raises a lot of issues
that we haven't really
gotten into today.
And so what I wanted to do
was look quickly at how some
of these issues are
dealt with in Europe.
So do European moral rights
apply to U.S. citizens?
The answer is yes.
No. Maybe.
So even as we go through these,
when you're looking at countries
that are the home of hardcore
statutory moral rights,
there's not a lot of agreement.
For foreign work,
which country's law defines
the initial holders --
who is the initial holder
of the moral rights?
In other words, choice of law.
In some countries,
it's the local law.
In some countries, it's
the country of origin.
kind of unresolved.
Who gets the moral rights in
a work created by an employee
on the job, in fact,
a work made for hire?
Some countries, it's
the employee.
Some, it's the employee.
In still others, there
are no moral rights
in a true work for hire.
Who is the moral rights author
of an audio/visual work?
It's all over the place.
In almost every country,
it includes the director.
Some countries include
the composer; some do not.
Some include the
producer; some do not.
Several, as you see here,
France and Brazil
include possibly others.
In some countries,
it's undefined.
Who has the moral
rights in a performance?
Some countries, it's
the performers.
As was mentioned, I think
it may have been Duncan
who mentioned it this morning.
In some countries, there are no
moral rights in a performance.
If there's more than one holder
of moral rights you will have
in a collective work, can one
holder alone block an act?
In some countries, yes;
some countries, no;
some countries, unresolved.
After the holder's death,
do moral rights survive?
This is an easy one.
Yes. In every country
that has moral rights,
they always survive death.
If post death, there's
more than one successor,
can that successor
alone block an act?
In some countries, yes;
some countries, no;
some countries, not so clear.
Is a contractual agreement to
waive moral rights enforceable?
Can you waive away
your moral rights?
In some countries, no; some
countries, yes; some countries,
no, but -- What about
limiting it?
Can you agree not to
waive it but to limit it?
Again, some countries, no;
a few more countries, yes,
but with limitations, usually
where it's a yes, but --
it's a yes, but for a
very specific agreement
to waive a very specific use.
So what all of this
does, I think,
is highlight the complicated
nature of moral rights
when you're talking about film
and television, and
collective works.
And that even in the countries
that have these robust,
long-standing statutory
moral rights regimes,
there's not agreement
on how you deal with it.
So what is the best
way to deal with it?
My view of the solution is --
and again, just talking
about film and television --
that effective collective
bargaining is the best way.
And I'll stop there because I
think a little later we're going
to talk about collective
bargaining
and how it actually works.
>> Maria Strong:
Thank you, Scott.
Alec.
>> Alec French: Sure.
Well, the Directors Guild
of America has long believed
that due to the unique
nature of filmmaking,
its members deserve recognized
statutory moral rights.
I think the best way to
explain this or to explain why,
is I think a really eloquent
letter that the Directors Guild
and the Writers Guild submitted
to the House Judiciary Committee
for a hearing they did
in July 2014 on this.
Just to quote from it briefly,
"Funding a motion
picture is not the same
as actually creating it.
Holding a copyright does
not confer artistic talent
on a corporate entity.
Rather, it is the writer and
director's creativity and vision
that is decisive
to telling a story.
A myriad of intensely personal
and visionary creative decisions
give life to the motion picture.
Creative expression like
authorship is a human,
not a corporate, quality.
We believe that authorship has
to do with creative vision,
and that moral rights
reside with those
who have that vision."
So that's kind of
the starting point
for how the Directors Guild
looks at these issues.
And then to the second part
of the question Maria asked,
I think the biggest
challenge that directors face
in asserting moral rights is a
combination of two facts: one,
there are no meaningful
statutory protections
for moral rights in the U.S.
; and two, and this is what
Scott pointed out, in the U.S,
motion pictures are
considered works made for hire.
And so directors effectively
don't have any statutory right
to control the motion
picture after creation.
>> Scott Martin: Adding
to what Alex said,
not only do we not have
moral rights legislation
in this country, something
we haven't talked about today
that affects the DGA
initial particular,
is we have anti-moral
rights legislation,
which is the Family
Movie Act of 2005.
I think Mary Beth
just passed out.
[ Laughter ]
That creates a right to
alter a motion picture
to take out the smutty bits.
[ Silence ]
>> Stanley Pierre-Louis: I
hope that wasn't a lead-in.
[ Laughter ]
So ESA represents the
video game industry,
and really it's U.S interests,
both on the U.S. publisher side
and the game consoles.
I'll touch a little bit on
international,but I'll veer
as much away from it as possible
since that's the province
of some other groups.
The interesting thing about the
way video game companies are set
up is that they are
partially like film studios,
television studios,
record companies.
And they are partially
like software companies.
So on the one hand there are
third-party collaborations
that occur where someone has
created a particular property
and that either gets acquired
or gets put into a larger work,
or maybe it is the work
that gets distributed.
On the other hand, many video
game companies actually hire
everyone, including the
composers and everyone else.
And so everyone is an employee.
And so you've got this dichotomy
of both how specific
record companies are run,
and how the industry may work
in an acquisition
phase or otherwise.
But under both models,
what becomes difficult is
distribution if you need
to get permissions all
along the way outside
of that initial model.
Because under the U.S. construct
at least, work for hire
and licensing of that nature
helps in terms of flexibility
and setting expectations
assembling the rights.
In other countries, as I talked
to some of my colleagues abroad,
particularly in France,
the key there is
to have good relationships
with third-party authors
because moral rights regimes are
so much stronger that you've got
to make sure that you're
creating those relationships
to get things moving.
And that ends up being the
key beyond any contract
because if people feel like
you're using their work
in a positive light and a
way that they intended it
to be portrayed, things get
approved much more quickly.
And so the American side of
companies, when they look
at what happens, particularly
in Europe, are glad not
to have a moral rights regime
because it helps to be able
to assemble those
rights moving forward.
And I think the challenge
really is how do you change all
of the expectations that
have built up over time
onto the construct, particularly
if you have a company
that hires lots of
the collaborators
that make up a video game.
And I think that's going to
be one of the challenges,
is how you maintain
expectations while looking
at the way the companies are
really set up in the U.S.,
at least in our industry.
>> Roxana Robinson: So I'll talk
a little bit about moral rights
and also how they
affect the public.
Somebody raised that
question earlier saying,
"How does this benefit
the public
if we're protecting the moral
rights of the creators?"
We've heard that the moral right
accrues to a work that's created
by a single individual,
only that individual could
create this particular piece
of work -- this book --
I'll talk about books.
And as you have heard, the
Supreme Court has decided not
to hear our case, the case that
we brought up Google Books.
And I'll talk about that
a little bit in terms
of the way it affects our
authors and their works.
So one of the things that we
believe should be contained
within the idea of
moral rights is
that you have control
over your work.
You created it and you
should be able to control it.
At the very least, you
should be consulted,
your permission should be
asked for if your work is going
to be put into an enormous
database and disseminated
to the public at the
will of the aggregator
and it will have
nothing to do with you.
So we feel that that is
a real problem in terms
of the moral right
of the creator.
So what has happened,
the moral right
and the fair use notions
have become sort of blurred.
So what Google Books did
was to take 20 million texts
without the permission of
the writers and put them
into a database which is
accessible by anybody.
So I'll describe a situation
in which that usage is made
and how it affects the public,
and how it affects the writer.
So we have a student who needs
to write a paper
on "Anna Karenina".
She goes to her computer
because it's easier than going
to the library, and she types in
to Google Books "Anna Karenina,
Leo Tolstoy, divorce".
She only needs to
know a little bit.
She wants to write in
her paper about the fact
that Leo Tolstoy's sister
had a disastrous affair,
she had a child out of wedlock,
and she considered suicide.
The student wants to
know when that happened,
when Tolstoy died, and when
the book was published.
It's very easy on Google Books.
A woman called Rosamund
Bartlett wrote a great biography
of Tolstoy and it's there.
The student signs in, finds
those facts, and signs off.
She doesn't need
to buy the book.
The library doesn't
need to buy the book.
So it's done.
However, Rosamund Barlett
-- I don't know her,
so I'm assuming this -- but
I'm assuming that she took
at least five years to
write this biography.
She went to Russia, she
interviewed Russians.
She might have learned
Russian for this biography.
She read critical works,
she read Tolstoy's works.
She created a unique
version of Tolstoy's life.
She proffered that
to a publisher.
The publisher gave
it peer review.
The publisher edited
it, copyedited it,
made it into an object, and put
it out into the world for sale.
Now, as an economic model,
the work of those two people
cannot be duplicated forever
if there are no sales
transactions.
Libraries traditionally have
been the great financial
supporters of non-fiction.
So academics have
depended enormously --
people who write books
for the academic public --
have depended on the libraries
and the library systems.
But Google Books can take
the work of anyone they want.
They have taken the works of
20 million writers and put it
into a database that
gives no compensation
to the writers or
to the publishers.
That's a model that
cannot be sustained,
and that will cause
harm to the public.
If we cannot keep producing
excellent works that are created
over periods of time through
a great deal of research
and intellectual content,
that are peer-reviewed
and properly edited, the student
must find the right information.
She cannot rely on Wikipedia
or somebody's Facebook page.
That is not going to do it.
So she has to go to
a professional source
with material that is
absolutely reliable.
She goes to a book
that's been published
by a professional publisher.
Interestingly, Chris sent me
an article about Google Books
that was published in 2009
when they were being accused
of doing this in a way that
was damaging to the writers.
And Sergey Brin, who is
a co-founder of Google,
said ingenuously, "We feel
that this Google Books is
part of our core mission."
This is news to all of you.
"There is fantastic
information in books."
[ Laughter ]
"Often when I do research, what
is in a book is miles ahead
of what I find on a website."
Who knew?
[ Laughter ]
But the point is that books
are actually necessary
for a society.
It is necessary for the
culture to have access to them.
And in order to keep
producing good books,
we have to have compensation.
That's all.
>> Maria Strong: Thanks, Roxana.
Chris.
>> Chris Castle: Well, I would
just add that one of the things
that doesn't get discussed a lot
with Google Books is
the non-display uses,
also known as corpus
machine translation,
for those of you reading
along, which is how they have
such a translation engine.
Because when you teach
a machine languages,
you do it by comparing
text strings.
And one of the ways you
get a lot of text strings
that are identical
phrasing is to have books
that have been translated
into a variety of languages
which the publisher paid for,
which the author approved.
Right. So anyway, I can go on
for a long time about that.
So I wanted to talk a little bit
specifically about songwriters
and recording artists who are
subject in one way or another
to -- some might call it the
boot heel of the government,
or others might call
it compulsory licenses
under Section 114 and 115
in the Copyright Act --
or what I would call
near compulsory licenses
under the ASCAP/BMI
consent decrees.
So while there are
reporting requirements
for royalty accounting in
these compulsory licenses,
there's virtually no
attribution requirement in them.
So for example, if you were to
check, I would put even money
on this, that the
most-used artists
on Sirius XM is "various
artists".
The reason it's various artists
is because Sirius doesn't go out
and buy the album for every
hit that they want to play
on the radio; they go out and
they buy a compilation record.
And then they rip that
compilation record --
which they're allowed to
do -- into their system.
And there's someone, usually
a minimum wage employee
who we also used
to call a teenager,
who is doing data entry,
right, in their system.
And they come to "who's
the artist," and they look
on the label copy and it
says "various artists."
So they put in "various
artists."
Right? And there's nothing
that requires Sirius
to do much more than that.
So consequently, when that
kind of reporting comes
to an organization like Sound
Exchange or somebody who has
to figure out who to pay
and how much to pay them,
they're looking at various
artists and they're trying
to figure out well,
what does that mean?
And so then they have to go
back and take the song title
and so on, and so on, and so on.
Whereas, if there had
just been a requirement
of proper attribution for
the artist, in that case,
in the first place, that
wouldn't have been a problem,
or would have been
less of a problem.
And it wouldn't have
turned so much on how
that data entry person
was feeling that day.
I would also point out that
no digital retailer requires
delivery of songwriter credits,
producer credits,
or musician credits.
So iTunes has no
requirement that anybody,
any label that's uploading --
or as they call it, rather,
discomfortingly, "ingesting"
music into their system,
actually provide them
with substantial credits.
In fact, there was not even
a place for composer credits
in the iTunes info
section, which you can check
when you go home, that even
had a slot for composer.
Now they have a slot for
composer, but that's sort
of voluntary on the part
of the record company
as to whether they're going to
actually input any data there,
and there's nobody that checks
whether it's right or not.
This is really bizarre
when you stop and think
that record companies have
extraordinarily detailed label
copy management systems where
they keep track of all of this.
Because when you put out a
CD, for example, someone,
mainly the artist
usually, approves all
of the credits that
go on that CD.
And they want to have at
least the songwriter names,
they may put the publisher
names on there too.
That lives in the background
in the label copy
management system.
So if you see songwriter
names on the label,
on the actual inlay card or
the actual credits in the CD,
somewhere in the background
in the label copy management
system, because it feeds
into the mechanical royalty
system, there is the names
of all of these publishers
that go with the songwriters.
There's producer names,
there's musician names.
There's a whole generation
of people that's growing
up not knowing who
played on what.
And that's mostly because
there's really no attribution
requirements that are
meaningful for any
of these digital retailers.
Whereas on the label side,
you would tend to have them
because they still put
out things in physical.
There's going to come a day
when that's no longer the case.
Right. So we haven't
gotten that, you know,
we're not at that
inflection point.
But that day is coming.
Yet, on the song side, the
songwriters can't say no.
They have to license.
They have to license
under those conditions.
They have to license regardless
of whether the person has paid
their mechanical royalties,
knows who they are,
knows who to pay.
That person can continue
getting compulsory licenses.
If they've never
credited one songwriter,
they can continue getting
compulsory licenses.
Now, you can always sue, but
as we've heard earlier today,
for the individual creator,
the individual songwriter,
particularly as we go
circling down the drain
in the declining revenues
of the digital reality
in the music business,
those people aren't
going to sue anybody.
So I just wanted to point out
there's this nexus between --
that would be I think
a pretty easy fix --
although I'm sure the copyright
office is in full compliance --
but it would be a pretty easy
fix to say well, if you're going
to get a compulsory license,
then here is what else
you have to do too.
>> Maria Strong:
Thank you, Chris.
Thank you, all.
What I'd like to do is -- we've
had a lot of conversation today
on a couple of issues:
contracts, technology,
the role of fair use and how
it plays into moral rights,
questions about commercial
speech.
So as follow-up on what Scott
started, I'd like to kind
of follow-up with
everybody a little bit more
on what do you think the key
contractual terms or elements
that you have in your industry
that offer these moral rights
type style of elements.
I mean, we've heard
mentioned already some
of the collective bargaining
and some guild contracts.
But if we can maybe start
a little bit with that,
and if you can be specific
on what are the elements
that support that kind of
morals rights like solution.
>> Scott Martin: Well, in
my world, which is governed
by collective bargaining,
which as I said,
I think where it's available and
applicable is the best solution.
It comes out of the
guild agreements.
So for example, the
WGA Agreement,
the Writers Guild Agreement,
specifies the writing.
And as you know, we
cannot stop ourselves
from hiring writers on movies.
It's never good enough to
have one, you're going to have
to have two or three or four.
And then it becomes an
issue over who gets credit,
who gets story by credit,
who gets written by credit.
And all of that is
governed by the WGA.
We submit a notice of proposed
credit, but it's the Guild
who decides who gets the credit.
Which is why no matter how
powerful Michael Bay is
as a producer and director,
you will never see him
get a writers credit on a
"Transformers" film, because the
Guild will never give it to him.
Just by a show of hands,
how many people know
the difference --
when you see a movie credit or
writers credit for two names,
and there's an "and,"
A-N-D, between them
or an ampersand between them?
How many of you know
what the difference is?
[ Laughter ]
I see one and a half hands.
An ampersand means that
they wrote as a team;
and an and means they
wrote sequentially.
Even a copyright/moral
rights-aware group doesn't
know that.
But believe me, the
writers know that.
Similarly with SAG, with
the Screen Actors Guild
for performers, we have a
whole list of requirements
that there has to be a
separate card for the actors,
it has to be readable
in terms of color, size,
and speed, so we can't fly past.
We are required to list
a minimum of 50 actors,
and that's what's
called the SAG card.
It's one of the first cards
you see in the end titles.
There are very significant
financial penalties
if we either don't do it at
all or don't list all 50.
There is an obligation
to correct a print.
So if we get it wrong, we
have to correct prints even
after they're in distribution.
Beyond that, we are required
by the collective
bargaining agreement
with the Screen Actors Guild
to obligate exhibitors,
distributors, broadcasters,
not to cut the credits off.
So AMC Theatres,
in order to squeeze
in one more showing a day,
can't cut five minutes
of credits off the
end of the film based
on our contractual
obligation with them.
Those are levels of protection
that you'll never
get from a statute.
And that's why I think where
it's available as it is
with commercial film
and television,
the direct negotiation
is the best route.
Just to say real quickly,
there's also integrity issues,
integrity rights that
come out of this.
We've been focused a
lot on attribution.
But the Screen Actors
Guild has a reuse clause
that we cannot reuse a
performance in any other work
without the permission
of the performer.
If we do it without the
permission of a performer,
there's a financial penalty
which is three times
the daily rate
for the actor times the
number of days it took
to film the scene, times the
number of actors in the scene.
So it's a very significant
financial deterrent.
But at the same time, there's
a bouncing because I talked
about the veto right and
how does it work statutorily
where you have a collective
work -- one author says,
"I'm cool with this new
use," and another author
of the same work says, "No."
Under the Screen Actors
Guild, if there's a holdout,
basically all of the actors
consent to the new use,
consent to the financial
terms, but there's one holdout,
we can submit it to the
SAG board of directors.
And the SAG board of
directors decides whether
or not they can override
that one holdout actor.
So there's a mechanism, and
it's a mechanism that's run
by the performers
to get around that.
>> Maria Strong: Others?
>> Alec French: I guess just
following up in the movie theme,
Scott's absolutely right.
Through collective bargaining,
some of the talent has managed
to secure creative rights.
As I've become familiar with
over the last couple weeks,
it's all right here
in the Creative Rights
Handbook for Directors.
And there are things that
are facsimiles of a right
of attribution and rights
of integrity that you'd find
in a moral rights regime.
On the credit side,
"directed by" is the credit --
the attribution that's
given to the director.
There are very specific
rules on the lettering,
the size of the lettering.
It's either the last credit you
see before the movie starts,
if the credits are
at the beginning,
or the first credit you
see at the end if that's
where the credits are.
So that is a facsimile of
our right of attribution.
And there's a facsimile on
the right of integrity side.
There's something called the
director's cut where again,
through collective bargaining,
directors have the right
to present the producer with
the version of the movie --
their cut -- after a set
number of actual weeks
that they're allowed to prepare
that cut, and they're allowed
to present that to the person
in the production studio
who has authority
basically over the movie,
not over someone below them.
And no one can cut
behind and kind
of change it before
it goes to the person.
So there are hard-fought
creative rights that are part
of the collective bargaining
agreement that are similar
to what you'd find in
a moral rights regime.
But I want to be clear,
that still doesn't mean
that Directors Guild
feels that it's complete,
that all of the rights
that they'd
like to be protected are
protected against all
of the parties they'd like
them to be protected against.
>> Stanley Pierre-Louis: Yeah.
In our industry, it can
vary widely depending
on the company, how
the game is made.
Often times, it'll be a lead
designer who leads the effort.
There might be a producer --
which I'll talk about
in one second.
But there have been reports
that Grand Theft Auto,
one of the big games put
out by Take-Two Interactive,
it took 300 people to
put that game together.
And they roll these
out every few years.
And you can imagine
trying to figure out all
of the various credits
of someone who came
in for this portion
or that portion,
it can get kind of complicated.
But often times, a lead designer
or designers will be the ones
who get a lot of the credit.
In Japan, there's a
phenomenon of producers.
Those of you who have not played
modern games probably aren't
aware that they feel very much
like reality or like movies.
They have storylines, they have
plots, and they change depending
on what your character does.
And they very much
are cinematic.
Last year's E3, which is a
big expo for the retailers
in the video game space,
where retailers see the
new games coming out,
there were lines out
the door for a few
of the Japanese producers
who were visiting
because people rarely
get to see them here.
And so they really are treated
like rock stars and the likes
of J. J. Abrams kind of comment
on works and play their games.
It's very cinematic.
But that's where it
becomes complicated;
is it more like a film or
is it more like software?
And it will be very dependent
on the structure of the game
and the structure
of the company.
>> Roxana Robinson:
The best protections
that authors have
traditionally enjoyed has been
that of copyright, and
that has protected the work
until we entered the
world of digitalization
and electronic publications.
So authors have lost a
good deal of protection
that copyright offered once
their books can be taken
without permission and put
into other people's
databases and disseminated.
What we would like to do at
the Guild is to create a system
that will offer some kind
of market-based collective
licensing,
and we're working on that.
Other than that, there
are other issues.
Generally speaking, authors do
have the rights of integrity,
but we're seeing
some kind of odd sort
of piratical incursions
into people's books.
And we're seeing
people's works translated
into foreign countries --
into foreign languages
and sold there,
sometimes with a
gender reversal.
So it will be a romance
book -- heterosexual --
and it will turn up in
Germany being homosexual.
Same book, same title, different
author, but a pirated version.
So these are things
that are going
to be very complicated
to deal with.
I don't have a solution
right now
where every time something new
comes up, we have to figure
out a different way
of dealing with it.
So I think the digital
era is just going to keep
on offering new possibilities
in every direction;
directions that we want
to go in and directions
that we don't want to go in.
>> Chris Castle: Speaking of --
I'm not sure it speaks generally
about both songwriters
and recording artists
because you get at kind of
the same way in their deals.
So if a recording artist is
signing with a major label
in particular, but
really any label,
and if a songwriter is
signing like a co-publishing
and exclusive administration
agreement
with a music publisher,
you typically will ask
for something called
marketing restrictions.
And these are sometimes
commercial in nature,
but more often than not, they
are more in the integrity range.
So you would say, for example,
you can't license my recording
for advertising really of
any kind by the time you get
through all of the
different examples.
You can't license my
recording for a sample.
recording in certain types
of motion pictures
or television.
You can't release my
recording in certain kinds
of compilation records.
So there'll be a number
of these exclusions
that the record just is agreeing
upfront that they won't do.
Now, that really comes
across in the first draft
as a general rule.
Now, there are things
that are leverage points
that go beyond that.
And depending on the artist,
the artist may have some
particular bugaboos, you know,
that they want to see
written in that contract,
even though you say to yourself
there is no way the label is
ever going to do this;
but they want to see it.
And some of these are
not trivial either.
I mean, there was a time
before the end of Apartheid
where it was absolutely
standard to have your artist ask
to have their records
not distributed
in South Africa,
and you'd get it.
No one would argue with you.
The leverage point really comes
in more whether it's
during or after the term.
So I'm not saying that
there's not a sense of leverage
and how bad they want to sign
you, or if it's a renegotiation,
how bad they want to
give you new terms.
So realize, if you say it's
during the term, then that means
as long as that artist is
a current roster artist,
let's say, or is still in
contract with a publisher,
then these restrictions
would apply.
If it's after the term,
that means forever.
Right. So when you stop and
think that record companies
and music publishers
carry unrecouped balances
that historical dollar
figures do not charge interest,
and those will never
increase based on inflation.
Telling somebody they can't
ever license your recording
for something that
might be a nice payday
that would help you get recouped
and help them recover
their investment is kind
of a tough conversation.
But it can be done, or it can
be done in a limited number
of circumstances at least.
So that's sort of
how it's addressed,
similar to the way
the guilds do it.
But it's addressed in a one-off
because featured recording
artists don't have their
own union.
While they may be members of
the AFM or they may be members
of SAG-AFTRA, they don't --
as in their capacities --
featured recording artists
have anybody negotiating
on their behalf in a
collective bargaining agreement.
>> Maria Strong: I'd like to
follow-up on your point there,
Chris, about market
restrictions.
Earlier sessions
today have talked
about issues involving
circumstances
where the author may find
their work being used
in objectionable circumstances,
whether it's a commercial
speech issue, a political ad.
I was curious to know, to those
of you who are copyright owners,
maybe not the initial individual
artist, but can anyone chime
in on your thoughts
about how you want to
or how do you control or somehow
guide uses in those cases
where maybe circumstances
involve objectionable contents
that you might not want to
see your work associated with,
your final work product?
Anyone can chime in.
>> Chris Castle: Well, I
can talk about samples.
Right.
>> Maria Strong: Yeah.
>> Chris Castle: I used to work
at A&M Records in Los Angeles
for a number of years.
And during sort of the 90s where
we had a lot of sort of the rise
of hip hop and we had a lot
of sample requests
that would come in.
And so we had to decide what
we were going to do as a label
about these sample requests
and how we were going
to approach it.
So basically what I
decided to was I said, "OK.
I'm going to take my
cue from the artist
who is being sampled," in
other words, our artist.
"And if that artist, regardless
of whether they have the right,
regardless of whether
they're in contract,
regardless of anything; if
that artist wants to be sampled
in this way and have
their recording used
in the requested way,
then I will back them.
I will then take over the
commercial terms, you know,
so I'm not completely
giving up our control.
But I will take my
initial cue from them.
And I don't care how
much money they offer.
I don't care what it is.
If our artist doesn't
want to do it,
we're going to back our artist.
Or alternatively, if our artist
does want to do and I don't want
to do it -- " which is
what happened with Sting
on "Every Breath You Take"
that Puffy sampled, I thought,
"That's like, karaoke, man.
I mean, why do I
want to do that?"
You know, but we did it
because Sting wanted to do it.
And I said, "OK.
In for a penny, in for a pound.
That's how we do
things around here."
But we didn't have to.
Right. We made a
conscious decision
that it's more important
to us --
if we ever thought enough
of that artist to sign them
to A&M Records, you
know, if Herb Alpert
and Jerry Moss wanted to be
in business with that artist,
then we were going to back
the artist in that situation
and let them control how
they wanted their persona
to be replicated.
>> Maria Strong: Thanks.
Others?
>> Scott Martin: I think because
of the season we're in right now
where you hear some of these
claims is when works are used
in political advertisements.
And I think it's more often with
music when a candidate tries
to use an iconic song as sort
of their anthem at rallies.
And you've heard about
Bruce Springsteen going
after politicians
who've done this.
Neil Young has gone
after some people.
It occasionally comes
up with movies and TV
where clips are being
used in advertising.
I would say most of it
is in local campaigns:
school board campaigns,
local mayoral
where they're creating
the campaigns themselves,
there's not a big budget.
And either they don't have
copyright or trademark advice,
or they just don't think
anyone is ever going to see it.
When we do get complaints
in those situations,
99 percent of the time, it's
from the opponent in the race.
[ Laughter ]
As opposed to the talent.
And for us it's a little
tricky because there is some --
our works are generally
not being used like a theme
of the campaign the
way a song might be.
So we're not as concerned
about passing off.
If you're talking
strictly about copyright,
it might be a good
fair use argument.
We also worry about going after
somebody who then gets elected
to a very high office.
I think in the 24 years
I've been at Paramount,
I remember one incident where we
went after a national campaign,
and it's because one of the
most iconic, famous directors
in Hollywood, his granddaughter,
who actually moved in with him
when she was 8 years old,
because she once told me
that he was a lot more
interesting than her parents,
was very upset in the last
election, a republican running
against Obama was
using a clip from one
of her grandfather's movies
and altering the clip.
And this individual is a fairly
well-known lifelong republican,
so it wasn't even
a political thing.
She was very upset about her
grandfather's work being altered
and misused.
And we contacted the campaign.
At that point we didn't
know who was going to win,
so we were very friendly
with them.
And they agreed to
stop running it.
So we do ask.
>> Maria Strong: Yeah.
Alec.
>> Alec French: I mean,
I guess I'm going to come
at this a slightly different
way because objectionable is
in the eye of the beholder.
And Scott mentioned the Family
Entertainment and Copyright Act
of 2005 which I had the
great pleasure of working
on when I was on House
Judiciary Committee.
And that's a case
where directors found what
this company, ClearPlay,
was going to do with DVD
movies to be objectionable.
They created software
that was going
to enable the consumer using the
software to excise, as you said,
all of the naughty bits: sex,
swear words, could have also
in another generation of the
technology excise violence
or whatever was considered
objectionable.
Well, to a director,
obviously, you talk about right
of integrity and attribution,
one, they don't maybe want
to be associated
with what's presented
on the consumer's screen that
is not their artistic vision;
or two, they don't want
to let someone do this,
basically destroy their movie
and their vision of their movie.
Now, the problem is
that at that point
in time the studios did not want
to take a case against
ClearPlay.
The copyright case probably
wasn't a very good one,
and it was also a
politically-charged time,
so going against companies
that are trying to clean
up movies wasn't the
politically smart thing to do.
But that left directors
with really no recourse
because they don't have
statutorily recognized
moral rights.
And they did bring a Lanham
Act claim that wasn't --
you know, they filed a suit.
And of course, all of this ended
up exploding into legislation
that actually, as Scott
said, rolled back, you know,
made things worse for directors.
But the point -- and I heard
this brought up, I wasn't able
to be here all day --
but clearly one thing
that's been discussed,
and this is the core
of the concern,
is in a collective bargaining
agreement with the studios,
directors can secure certain
types of rights, attribution,
and integrity, and have, and
can potentially even have those
rights extend to parties with
whom the studios are in privity.
And there are areas
where we've done that.
But with regards to a third
party that has no privity
with the copyright owner,
directors don't have any ability
to protect what they
consider to be their rights
of attribution and integrity.
So there, really, when they
see something objectionable,
there's not much
they can do about it.
>> Scott Martin:
I always thought
that was a very interesting
act by Congress,
to say that you have a right to
watch a movie the way you want
to watch, as opposed to
just not watching it at all.
When we were making the
last "Jackass" movie
and I would come home
at dinner and talk
about the unbelievable things
the Jackass boys were doing
that day, and my boys who
were in elementary school
at the time would say, "Daddy,
when do we get to
see the movie?"
And the answer was, "Never."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, the answer was, "You
can watch it when hell freezes
over or Mommy goes out of town."
[ Laughter ]
And about a year later, my
wife went out of town and one
of the boys said to me, "OK,
we're watching "Jackass"
tonight."
And I said, "It was a joke."
And they said, "No,
it was a contract."
So clearly --
[ Laughter ]
-- there's a future
lawyer in the family.
>> Maria Strong: Just to
follow-up, earlier today,
Professor Ginsburg made some
interesting observations
on the possibility of taking
a new look at the first prong
of the Fair Use doctrine.
What do you guys all think
about what she said today?
And how might that
play into your issues
in protecting moral rights
for your constituencies,
to the extent -- I'm saying
moral rights moral rights-like.
>> Scott Martin: One
thing that is interesting
about that concept is
I think there are a lot
of different impediments
to get moral rights
legislation in this country.
But one of the big
ones I think is the
one-size-fits-all mentality.
And to come up with a statute
that works for a photographer
or an individual
writer, but also works
with a collective work or work
where there are very strong
collective bargaining rights --
if you try to have one size
fits all, you're not going
to satisfy all of those.
And even when you look
to the European examples,
essentially they do not have
effective collective bargaining
in Europe for writers,
directors, and actors.
And that's partly
for antitrust reasons
that they're not allowed.
My wife for many,
many years was head
of the International
Federation of Actors in London.
Worked on unionizing
performers around the world.
And it's a real challenge
for them not to organize,
but to bargain collectively
because of antitrust laws.
And one thing I like about
the idea of working it
into the fair use factor is
it's not one size fits all.
You would be able
to look at things
like is there a collective
bargaining agreement,
or is it a collective work.
So I think that's an
interesting concept.
>> Stanley Pierre-Louis: I think
the other thing there would be
what is this scope of what
we might call moral rights.
So as I said before, in the U.S.
it's different than in Europe
for our companies where a
moral rights question --
if there's someone who's
owed the right of attribution
and integrity, they confer.
In the U.S., the issue
doesn't come up as much,
but what does come up are right
of publicity claims in cases
in which real life people claim
to be depicted in games just
because their numbers, weight,
size in a game might be similar
to how they actually play, and
the position might be the same.
[ Laughter ]
And how do you deal with that?
And is that something that gets
codified in some different way
than the way that it's
been dealt with now?
And the way it's being dealt
with now is actually
rather confusing.
I think there was
a cert petition
that was denied a few weeks ago
in the Electronic Arts case.
But that would have been a nice
way to try to figure out which
of the five various
tests was the one
that was most applicable
depending on the jurisdiction
in which you bring
your claim or reside.
And so I think scope is going to
be very important there as well,
because you're dealing not
only with personalities,
but historical figures,
and all kinds of depictions
that might require
a type of licensing
that might make certain
games not feasible to make.
>> Roxana Robinson: I agree with
the idea that it's not going
to be one size fits all.
And for writers -- I mean,
what we're seeing is
this gradual dissolution
of the notion that
writers have control
of their work like
other creators.
And the idea of moral
right is an inherent one.
It's something that
you can't lose.
This is something
that you have created.
It didn't exist before
it existed in your mind.
And you have a right
of intellectual ownership
over that property.
And we're seeing that
right being drained.
And so for example,
with our authors who all
of whose works were put
into this database
without permission.
The fact that piracy exists,
so that the owners now --
the burden now is on the
writer to try to track
down the pirates, the pirate
sites over and over and over,
and request takedowns.
And the pirates simply
put them back up.
So the idea of moral right --
a kind of moral ownership
of your work -- has
sort of vanished.
So I think we're going to have
to see more attention
being given to that notion
of inherent right
that the creator has,
which cannot be taken
away from him or her.
And we have to figure
out solutions,
collective licensing rights,
and situations in which it's not
up to the writer to try to
track down the pirates all
across the world and to
issue takedown notices.
There has to be a better
sense of protection
for the created works.
>> Chris Castle: I think you'd
have to square the lens case
with Article 27 of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
Which, you know, in
the Ninth Circuit,
we do a lot of considering,
but there's not consideration.
So I think that David Lowery
actually wrote a comment,
and I will speak for
him hopefully correctly,
as he had to leave.
He wrote a comment
on the 512 study
that the Copyright Office
is doing, where he said
that the way he reads the lens
case is he will essentially,
as an individual copyright
owner, have to go out
and get a legal opinion every
time he sends a takedown notice
to make sure that he's properly
considered fair use aspects
of the use by the
downstream user.
So how the moral rights issue
would fit in, if that's the law
and if the law is that
it's fair use for Google
to copy 30 million
books, it's really hard
to say exactly how moral rights
of any kind would fit into this.
But the reason I mentioned
Universal Declaration
of Human Rights is because that
article essentially acknowledges
-- although it's the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights,
so I don't know how much anybody
legally is really empowered
by that.
Although it's certainly
a relevant document
for the good-and-evil
aspect of this.
That article essentially states
that everyone is entitled
to the moral and material
benefits of their work.
So you know, if we're
going to go through
and explain what the benefit is
to the public for moral rights,
then let's start at Article
1 and kind of work our way
down and see how we do.
>> Maria Strong: Thanks, Chris.
I think we've run out of
time for questions here
from the dais, but we are going
to open it up to the floor,
so if the mics can get ready.
As the mics are coming
to you, I just wanted
to let you know I
received some news
that the resale royalty case
in California was
dismissed this afternoon.
Apparently the case -- it says
it was preempted by first sale.
So for those of you who
are following royal rights,
resale royalty, droit
de suite litigation.
There's the second
interesting piece
of litigation in the news today.
So we open this to the floor.
We did not get a chance to
talk about technology and CMI,
so perhaps folks from the
floor might have a question.
I'm looking.
Oh. To Ben Ivans.
>> Ben Ivans: Question
for Chris.
You had -- if I understand
correctly --
were noting that neither
compulsory licenses nor
collective agreements --
ASCAP/BMI consent
agreements address this issue.
Do you know if the songwriter
community has ever sought either
of those to be included?
I mean, have they have said
in ASCAP/BMI negotiations,
"We want to negotiate this"?
Have they ever talked about 115
or whatever saying this should
be an additional element,
or have they not pushed that --
>> Chris Castle:
I'm not aware of it.
But then again, the compulsory
license rate was two cents
for 65 years or so, you know.
So I don't know why that is, but
I'm sure someone has an answer
for it, but it is not me.
Given that it would be -- if
you just applied inflation
to the two-cent rate, I think
the compulsory license rate
would now be something like
85 cents instead of 9.1.
>> Maria Strong: Any
other questions out there?
I can't see.
Well, with that, let's stay on
tune and let's thanks the panel
for their participation and --
[ Applause ]
Thank you all very much.
We're going to start with the
close-up session right now,
so our two moderators
will come right on up.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.